before we get started let's introduce
you to edward page
a seven-year-old neuroblastoma fighter
tonight
it's time for braves baseball let's
play ball hey that's my line but edward
did it a heck of a lot better than i
ever had yes he did
and edward uh keep on fighting pal all
of brave's country is rooting for you
and i know you're rooting for max free
to pick up his seventh win
against the nationals tonight so a hit
batsman two walks and the nationals have
the bases loaded without a hit
and rick kranitz is going to have to
make a rare first inning visit with max
freed
so a golden opportunity for the fifth
place hitter kurt suzuki
ill have with the bases loaded won out
they got jammed there's no way they're
turning two
nats score a run and kurt suzuki with a
productive outscoring victor robles
well what a great spot for carter kibum
here
and he got jammed and drops it into
right field turner scores
27 year old right-hander eric finney
takes the bound at truist park in
atlanta with a two-nothing lead as we go
to the bottom of the first inning
great to have ronald back i'll tell you
that 17 lead off homers
for ronald lacuna junior in his young
career that ties in with felipe allu on
the all-time atlanta braves lead off
homer list
swing and a high fly ball lifted toward
left holt is back
at the track it is gone ron lacuna
junior has broken that record
another lead off homer and the braves
are on the board
i know we've seen him hot i don't think
i've ever seen him this hot it was
absolutely beautiful that's unbelievable
ben
and another lead off homer his 18th
[Applause]
team record gives him the franchise
record for leadoff homers in a career
and he's not even 24 years old
first pitch swing darno deep right
center field robles on the run
he'll look up the ball is bullpen bound
a home run for darneau
and the braves have taken the lead heck
yeah applaud that
sixth home run for darno
well one of my four keys today was long
ball
second one right now that backspin you
see him get on that ball
that's why it can it carries when you go
to right center the only way
chip really for a right-hander to go to
right turn you got to back that ball up
it's got to have that spin
braves by a run looking for more as adam
duvall
with a double under his belt high
pop fly down the left field line long
run hold he's not going to get there it
creeps over the wall
duval has hit his ninth home run the
braves of the
third home run of this game it creeps
over the boards and the braves extend
their
lead yeah look he didn't get it all he
got him
a curveball and adam got it off the end
but
when you go right down the line with
that short fence that's the place to go
turn her to right center goes down and
digs it out
row blaze easily to third
these two guys are turning into
something special
at the top of this lineup so runners at
the corners one out
here's howie kendrick and this didn't
look like what the nats wanted but the
throw gets away and a run scores
here's luis garcia pitch swinging a hard
ground ball right side off the glove of
the diving camargo it trickles into
shallow right center field
kibum scores the tying run holt races
for third as camargo picks the ball up
in shallow right center
and luis garcia delivers an rbi single
to tie the ball game at four
in the sixth inning and now with halted
third garcia at first here's victor
robles
here's the pitch and robles tries to
push the bunny pops it up it lands
freeman fields it
leads matic to the bag but he can't get
there in time and it's an rbi bunt
single for victor robles
holt will score garcia to second the
bunt popped up but it landed
freeman made a sliding stop and all
robles had to do was beat the pitcher to
the bag and he did
and the nationals play a little small
ball and robles has the rbi bunt hit
it's five to four
here's the offering to howie kendrick
howie waits for the breaking ball and
hammers it to left
center it is off the glove of duvall
trey turner motors around to score
and howie kendrick gets rewarded for
hitting the ball extremely hard the nets
six to four kurt suzuki is next
hurt suzuki gets on top of one
off the wall nets leads seven to four
and the nats catcher having a courageous
night in payne
puts his teammates on top by three and
brock
holt who came into this game as a nat
one for 13.
has a chance for a four hit night
he's going to do just that suzuki scores
key boom to second and the nets lead
eight to four
double single double single
rock hold ladies and gentlemen now it'll
be
luis garcia breaking ball and he
hammers it to the gap in right center
kibum will score
holt coming around he's headed for home
and the nats do add on a couple and make
it a
six run lead garcia a three rbi night
and the fate of freddy's hit streak
first rest in the hands of dansby
swanson
little pop fly to shallow right taylor
is
under it and that's gonna do it the
washington nationals came back from a
4-2 deficit to win
10-4 the braves went hitless
from the fourth inning on after duvall's
homer in that frame
and a tough night for the atlanta
bullpen is the best the braves can do
jeff
is go for a series split tomorrow
afternoon